Speaker 1: So I was not going to talk about
this because I genuinely didn't think that
it would need debunking, that it would need
a discussion, but sadly it does because there
is a new ivermectin and again study.
I hate to use the word study and you'll see
why shortly.
Because really, what we're talking about is
a conference abstract.
But there is a new purported ivermectin study
which all sorts of right wingers, including
Jordan Peterson and others have been promoting
and saying, Look, here's the proof.
Here's the proof that ivermectin, this cheap
drug is good for preventing death from COVID.
They've been covering it up, and we got it.
We got the information.
However, even the author of the paper says
that's not what the paper says.
We have retracted the paper, and there are
now actual better studies on this matter,
and people need to stop pointing to his paper
as proof that ivermectin works to prevent
death from COVID.
Now, as many of you might know.
If we want to test whether a medication or
treatment is worth using against a particular
disease or condition, the gold standard is
a double blind, randomized controlled trial,
which compares the treatment you're testing
against the standard of care at the time,
meaning the best known treatment that's available
at the time.
So for ivermectin, you would take a group
of people.
You would ensure that there are no difference,
but the differences between the groups in
terms of characteristics or that you've equalized
or adjusted for those differences in characteristics
you'd give half ivermectin, you'd give the
other half the standard of care.
The doctors shouldn't know who's getting what,
the patients shouldn't know, who's getting
what, and you compare the outcomes.
Does one group have a different outcome than
the other?
We actually have an rc t randomized controlled
trial on ivermectin, as I told you about back
in February.
That study is called efficacy of ivermectin
treatment on disease progression among adults
with mild to moderate COVID 19 and co-morbidities
that study a good study.
A properly done study found that ivermectin
doesn't work for treating COVID for preventing
death from COVID.
So we had that study, it was a very good study
and we thought it was finally time to put
the issue to bed.
But there is a new study, but it's not really
a study.
It's a conference abstract and it's actually
months old based on even older data, which
is being wildly distorted to claim that ivermectin
is extraordinarily efficacious for preventing
COVID deaths.
Now, as a reminder, I would love it if that
was the case because ivermectin is really
cheap.
If ivermectin were really effective at preventing
death from COVID, I would be thrilled.
I have no ideological horse in this race whatsoever,
but we have one good rc t that says ivermectin
doesn't work.
We've got to be really sure we have something
that gives us a different perspective.
Well, a lot of folks on the internet think
it does.
Dr. John Campbell, who's not a medical doctor
important to remind you, has been pushing
the study in a video called Ivermectin more
evidence that nearly has a million views right
now.
Dr. Pierre Corrie, another darling for the
ivermectin supporters, has pushed it, tweeting
quote massive study comparing the mortality
rates of patients treated with ivermectin
in those treated with remdesivir.
Shocker.
Large magnitude reduction in mortality if
treated with ivermectin.
The United States of pharma rages on.
Jordan Peterson pushing the study, tweeting
This should be a bombshell.
Treatment with ivermectin is associated with
decreased mortality in COVID compared to remdesivir.
They are distorting and misusing the report,
and even its author says so.
The author actually responded to each of these
people with comments similar to this one.
This comment was a response to Jordan Peterson,
where Yakub for Manko, the first author of
this paper, says quote Hi Dr. Peterson, first
author of the paper.
I think the information and data is being
crudely misrepresented and misinterpreted.
This is an abstract, not peer reviewed from
a conference I presented at.
We did not submit the manuscript for a reason.
Weak evidence?
OK, if it really were shown to work, that
would be great.
But that's not what its own author says.
This conference abstract is called abstract.
I'm sorry.
This is from the 8th International Meeting
on Emerging Diseases and Surveillance.
And this is a particular abstract about.
Ivermectin, it is months old and it is based
on data that's even older than that.
Since then, we've gotten an actual randomized
controlled trial.
This paper is a retrospective study, and it
compares people who took remdesivir to people
who took ivermectin based on everybody's recollections
without even knowing what doses of different
things people received.
The paper was also withdrawn, the paper was
withdrawn, and what people are claiming the
study shows is that if you got ivermectin,
you're 70 percent less likely to die than
if you got remdesivir.
But the problem is No.
One, it's a retrospective study looking at
stated data from the past about this.
They didn't stratify the patients by vaccine
status.
We don't know whether the same portion of
the people who got ivermectin.
Are whether the same portion of people who
got ivermectin were vaccinated versus the
portion of those who got remdesivir were vaccinated.
We don't know that the study didn't look at
that.
They didn't stratify for seriousness of disease.
In other words, it's possible that the people
who got remdesivir got it because they were
more sick.
So, of course, they were more likely to die.
This wasn't double blind.
It wasn't a randomized controlled trial.
Now, if you don't believe me, here's the coauthor
of the paper saying this that this is not
good for determining whether to use ivermectin.
Here's Yakub Flamengo.
Speaker 2: Of course, there are also many
potential confounders, cofactors and so on
confounders that are difficult to account
for in like a large retrospective observational
study.
You can't account for data that's not collected
and confounders that aren't there.
Is that a concern of yours in terms of the
strength of the inference from the study?
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, that's something that we elaborate
on in the full manuscript that I wrote that
we ended up with drawing because you just
don't have the space, you know, you're limited
to four or five hundred words in an abstract.
You can't elaborate any of those things if
you're trying to convey any kind of point
across.
But in the full manuscript that we wrote some
of the things that I wrote down here, I'll
go over.
So limitations.
Obviously, it's like a retrospective study,
so we cannot exclude possibility of confounding
factors as just the nature of retrospective
studies.
Treatment dosage with ivermectin was widely
varied.
There's no unified protocol like who knows
how much ivermectin each patient was receiving
because genetics doesn't have a way to, you
know, screen for dosages.
At that time, at least, there is significant
limitation for the ability to control for
COVID 19 vaccination.
Basically, we were unable to do that, and
that's something we also wrote in the manuscript.
So, yeah, basically vaccination status was
unaccounted for because trying to train medics
was unreliable for that because, you know,
people get vaccines at a gas station here
in Florida or like the church or whatever.
So pretty much anywhere that doesn't go in
your EMR.
And also, I think most importantly, we weren't
able to stratify patients based on severity
of disease at that time.
You know, it's very possible that patients
that were receiving remdesivir had a much
more complicated course of disease compared
to patients receiving ivermectin.
And I think that's like one of the major confounders
that study.
Yeah, that I've seen that discussed a little
bit in the discussions.
Speaker 1: So that's the author saying we
withdrew it.
We withdrew it.
It wasn't peer reviewed.
We didn't even know what dose of ivermectin
people were getting.
The studies being misused, there was no control
for vaccine status.
There was no control for severity of disease.
This is not a random critic.
This is not, you know, whoever.
This is the first author of the paper saying
it's not good data.
It's old data from a conference in November,
and we now have actual rc ts on ivermectin.
So just bear this in mind because you'll see
you'll go to different subreddits and you'll
see it on Twitter.
You'll see YouTube videos, people saying,
Look at this study.
Withdrawn non peer reviewed conference abstract
of a retrospective analysis of data.
Don't forget, I would love it if this worked.
This paper is not evidence
that
it does.